le conte finances a servi à rien
n'est fait bon si on n'avait pas confiné
y aurait pas eu plus de moeurs
non
tu aurais pas eu plus de morts en fait
l'émission tourne lancement
alain finkielkraut pas fait ça une fois
au centre la vraie vie et la foule et la
fosse l'y attendait la rime il va
rentrer en scène attention thomas 7 à
vous
[Musique]
ne pas chanter en entendant n'entend pas
programme de télématin évidemment tous
les chroniqueurs tous sont près de 5 6
minutes alors on n'est pas d'antenne
dans un petit quart d'heure
non non on n'est pas du tout une antenne
là on est entre amis donc bon évidemment
qu'on est un
formidable comparé à monsieur
finkielkraut je suis très honoré et très
bien passée
sera pas du tout pas sinon il s'est
passé des choses bizarres je serai à vos
côtés
non c'est fait du coup bien trente ans
de carrière pour
c'est comme ça qui drague arrivons dans
ses seins ils ont une forme de danse
mais dans cette danse là comme ils
affichent leurs couleurs puisqu'il ouvre
leur zèle et c'est là où les clés de la
coloration est la plus forte c'est là
qu'ils vont être plus attractif
donc là en gros c'est que des
célibataires c'est un site de rencontres
de flamants roses
non mais excusez moi parce que chez
midinettes camionnette et j'ai peur que
vous pensiez que c'était une
plaisanterie mais c'est passé voilà
c'est vrai je ne sais pas des flics vous
me faites mais je n'aime pas vous dire
mais vous êtes tellement brillant est
tellement beau je ne vais même pas pensé
un jour que je parlerai avec vous et
lâchés en train de me ridiculiser parce
que je suis toute ouïe haute devant
devant vous une petite chaudière
autrefois amoureuse d'une batterie ou de
la statue de la liberté amanda object
homosexuels crack un lustre personne ne
le sait pas y aller c'est la part afridi
elle est amoureuse d'objets vous vous
aimez amoureux de quelqu'un elle sait
les objets et on ne comprend pas qu'elle
dit mais tu m'étonnes qu on la comprend
pas comment on peut tout et une batterie
quand on est amoureuse d'un lustre
écouter
évidemment
je vais très très touché par tous ses
moyens
du sénégal consacré autant de temps
sinon beaucoup plus serré
j'aurais grand plaisir à vous rencontrer
mais je ne suis pas tout seul ma chère
c'est pas grave daniel aussi un animal
de compagnie scènes improbables filmé
par une sonnette connectés
[Musique]
alors qu elle réceptionne un colis une
anglaise aperçoit son chien sur le bord
de la fenêtre et le rattrape de justesse
heureusement qu'elle a devant réflexe
parce que le livreur est resté
totalement impassible
[Musique]
et
l art et un au milieu ou de l'arrêt du
plombier
[Rires]
je suis choquée sur chantier bat de
sarlat on connaissait la réduc l'envié
on connaît maintenant c'est deux
ouvriers
vont s'étaler sur pluton tu sais que tu
vas marignane à l'aéroport de marignane
ya marqué jesse jackson + temps je
croise une blague destination du temps
mais j'ai aimé nom n'est décidé mais ces
débits qui utilisera super méga cher à
voilà c'est pour ça qu'à deux cent
cinquante mille euros mais si jamais vu
- l'aéroport a annoncé faudrait pts et
explique à cette note le concept d'une
chauny c'est quoi
il ya encore des gens qui
je connais mon mec je crois qu'ils
n'hésitent pas tout car est belle je ne
la méritais pas grave bah ouais plus
temps ça n'existe pas quoi enfin pu tant
elles existent la bannette ne peut pas y
aller c'est obligé et sur un come back à
moi je suis sûr qu'il nous ment et
coquillages exprès tu peux aller coup de
paris basse et je sais pieux je n'ai pas
appris donc je ne sais pas
non non non non c'était s'éteint c'est
une un questionnement c'est pas un truc
c'est un question bon ok là si on n'a
pas entendu dit si
tu vois un truc de fusées la jan kounen
qu'on a pris une usine de fusée tu
prends une fusée tu vois à piolenc tu
penses tout drôle mais je t'aime trop en
jambes pleure de rire mais si c'est une
des bourses elle est vraiment bête ou à
le fesf est on est une pépite l' arbre
tu croises ovni ouais ouais
giuly le dire en plus désavoué ouais
ouais ça j'y crois c'est julie l'aurait
pas dit j'aurais jamais cru
[Musique]